thank you very much i do appreciate it
thank you i know
but
thank you it's uh
[Applause]
what a crowd thank you i know the people
are
they're crazy
it's the it's the fiscal new year so
people go nuts
well you know what that's the big story
i hate to have to bore you with all this
[ __ ] but it's all
no but that's all that america is
talking about the temporary funding bill
got passed we are not going to have a
government show uh slow shutdown so
that's good
i mean what are we
you're cheering because we made it
through to december 3rd that's what they
did
they they the democrats wanted to you
know raise the debt ceiling but no just
until december 3rd that's all the
republican is the equivalent of putting
duct tape on your shower nozzle until
you actually call the plumber you know
just
this stupid
this stupid stupid game of chicken that
they always play whenever a democrat is
the president and the republicans can
make them look like an [ __ ] and of
course at the last minute the democrats
had to back down nancy pelosi blinked uh
which is itself news
good job we joke here but
oh
did you see there's a new book out about
trump i love this everybody who worked
for trump for years completely loyal now
they hate his guts and they write a book
all right that's what i was really
thinking
so uh
stephanie grisham i don't even remember
this one
one of trump's many
press secretaries
wrote a book and uh she talked about all
the inside dirt apparently melania was
very angry about trump cheating on her
at one point she tearfully said i wish
he never ordered me
it's sad isn't it people
also i love this by the way i know biden
isn't perfect but just remember
it was only a year ago that [ __ ] like
this was happening get this at one point
trump called stephanie grisham from air
force one about his penis
that's
yeah
that's not happening under the current
administration i mean just just take our
uh
yes because remember stormy daniels said
it was shaped like a toadstool
so trump had to call her from air force
get it out there my dick is not shaped
like a toadstool
you see why he had so many press
secretaries i mean try working that into
a press release about the consumer price
index there's a job
you